Tình thử chiến của mình bánh giết thành phóa nội thành phố sử kiến thành lập sử dịch mới,
chính cơ sử sắp nhập sợ quý hoa kiến chó, vào sử dịch.
Sao sắp sợ sử dịch mới có mấy bốn phòng chiến mông, giảm mấy một phòng.
Sao đơn vị sử nghiệp công lập cùng năm chăm ha mi tám công chất và muốn chăm bà mi muốn biến chất.
Sở bán hoa tị tháo vào dù để cũng được thành lập chiến cơ sử sắp nhập sử dụi lịch, vào sử vấn hoa và thị tháo.
Cơ quan này dự kiến còn mười phòng chiến mông và mùi bốn nâng vị sử nghiệp công lập.
Hành phố hạn nội đồng thời dự kiến thành lập sử dụi vụ, chính cơ sử dịch mới,
chính năng nghiệp vụ, liên quan từ văn phòng quy bánh giết thành phố,
với bốn phòng và bốn năm công chất.
Măn phòng quy bánh giết thành phố sau tụ trước lại,
còn tảm thông chiến mông, một chăm mông, mốt công chất.
Các phương hạn chiến dự kiến được hộn giết thành phó hạn nội xem xét thông qua,
tại kinh học chiến đe dạng ngày 1,5 tảm.
Nếu đưa thông qua hạn nội sẽ không mười bốn sẵn,